for 27 years this has been eunice
howard's home
a house she built with her late husband
now ripped apart
a moment here of community support that
is replicated across this valley and
beyond
within
10 to 12 minutes
i hear the noise and i raised the window
and i seen the water and i knew i had to
get out there
it was in the house and my building
started coming out i said well my house
will be okay
about time my house come out
took about five minutes for that to
happen five to six minutes and it was
gone
from the time i got out of the house
eunice's granddaughter wanted to show us
the power of the water it's moved like 2
300 meters because the house didn't used
to be where it now sits so these are the
foundations yeah
my god
from above it's clear the foundations
below and several hundred meters
downstream what's left of the howard
family home
it is one of so many destroyed by rains
and floods that everyone here says they
have never seen before
the state governor has been absorbing it
all from the air this is remote kentucky
hard to reach hard to help so many who
have lost everything
the number known not to have made it
continues to rise
and devastating stories
four children from the same family
pulled from their parents arms as they
sought safety on the roof of a home
which collapsed underneath them
down the valley beyond eunice's house
people salvaging what they can
they will all need to start all over
again
but this is still a rescue operation
as a major disaster federal funding has
been provided and personnel too
this is still an emergency situation we
are in search and rescue mode
again that that count is going to
continue to go up and we don't lose this
many people in in flooding this is a
real tough one
it is a sentiment you hear over and over
now with so much extreme weather this
isn't normal